il attendait depuis plus d'une décennie
et enfin le grand jour est arrivé
[Applaudissements]
le chantier maritime des vies devient le
troisième joueur à part entière de la
stratégie nationale de construction
navale des contrats de plus de 8
milliards et demi de dollars à venir
pour construire cette brise glace vous
êtes en train de garantie qui va avoir
encore 3 4 5 générations de travailleurs
ici à au chantier des vies il y a pas de
raison que vous soyez pas parti des
contrats qui sont donnés par le
gouvernement fédéral vous êtes les
meilleurs pour satisfaire les critères
de tawa 840 millions de dollars doivent
être investis par la dévie et le
provincial pour moderniser le chantier
le gouvernement du Québec va investir
519 millions pour mettre à niveau les
installations des centaines de millions
de dollars notamment sous forme de prêt
pardonnable sans quoi les contrats
aurait pu échapper à Lévis encore une
fois le gouvernement se devait d'être là
partenaires pour aider le chantier à eux
aussi ce que nous avons fait moi
l'avenir de la famille qui veut y passer
ici fait que je suis bien content avec
les contrats du fédéral le chantier va
embauché au moins 1800 nouveaux
travailleurs au cours des prochaines
années ça faisait plusieurs années qu'on
en entendait parler puis là le concret
est arrivé il fait que ça va être
important pour tout le monde qui est ici
le maire de Lévy avait invité son père à
l'annonce lui qui a travaillé au
chantier Gilles laurier voit déjà
l'explosion économique à venir pour sa
ville déjà de nombreux entreprises nous
contactent et revenir voir les terrains
industriels disponibles etc parce que
près de 1000 fournisseurs répartis dans
10 régions de la province bénéficieront
aussi de la construction navale ça
représente je vous dirais probablement
l'équivalent entre 18 et 22000 23000
personnes qui travaillent un peu partout
dans ces entreprises là les
gouvernements croient qu'avec cette
annonce l'industrie maritime dans la
région deviendra aussi importante que
celle de l'aéronautique à Montréal et
celle de l'automobile en Ontario ici
Pierre-Alexandre Bolduc Radio-Canada
allez-y